[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
brothers and sister tonight the newest
member of our family feast for the first
time
bring the new blood
[Music]
brother Tyrell welcome to the first
night of your new and what are we
wearing here I'm just wearing what I got
bit here mm-hmm
okay do you have anything black or like
pants with laces up the side of the leg
to be quick so you can still see the
skin oh no that's not my style so I got
nothing at my closet or nothing like
that okay
anyway we will tonight Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
come on man excuse me I'm just saying
y'all over here licking and and hissing
and whatnot if we don't eat then let's
eat
damn yes of course we will all feed
[Music]
spread the meat
[Music]
the enemy of that actually get in your
mouth I mean now soon the one y'all is
hungry all the time oh no no no no see
look why y'all gotta hiss when you
flashin your fangs you know you can make
your teeth come out with y'all doing all
that nonsense see and can you two get a
room seriously y'all live in a damn
mention they got to be some other place
you can do that [ __ ] I mean are you two
even lesbians I just don't understand
what everything gotta be all sexual and
licky girls seriously man you got to get
your hands up off before I [ __ ] you up
[ __ ] is nasty creepy as [ __ ] and
touching my nipple for 15 minutes the
all this [ __ ] y'all is doing it bigger
this is just like straight-up gratuitous
I got bit on purpose so I could live
forever see future cars yes Cyrus these
pants are uncomfortable and I actually
have a boyfriend and this song has been
playing for like two years and it sucks
this just seems desperate okay desperate
really Tristan its Christian really his
name ain't even Tristan so do you all
feel this way yeah yeah kinda yeah
Wow it's like you can't even get good
friends no you're not even okay and
you're leaving now
that's I mean you know what no seriously
like you could fix this place up it'd be
dope though for real
our cars gonna be able to fly or is
everything going to be on a magnetic
track we do this Oh negative tastes like
pennies
oh sorry what dude hey come on now
nipple player for private family or just
like 2011 it's just a dream [ __ ] you
guys
you